الرحمن
الرحيم ان الله يدافع عن الذين امنوا ان
الله لا يحب كل خوان
كفور صدق الله
العظيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين القوي
المتين الناصر بالحق عباده المستضعفين ولو
بعد
حين والصلاه والسلام على الشاهد
والشهيد نبي الامه محمد صلى الله عليه
واله وسلم ثم اما
بعد لازلنا بفضل الله تبارك
وتعالى نواصل معركه الشرف
والصمود في حرب الاباده المفروضه على
شعبنا الفلسطيني
الاعزل والتي كان نواتها
بالاساس تراكمات اعتداء الاحتلال
والمستوطنين على المسجد الاقصى
والاسرى والانتهاكات
الصارخه بحق ابناء شعبنا في غزه والضفه
والقدس واحكام الحصار بذرائع
واهيه ادت في نهايه المطاف الى الانفجار
الكبير الذي حذرنا منه مرارا
وتكرارا
وعليه لن نكثر الحديث فالحقيقه باتت واضحه
جليه كيان صهيوني خارج عن كل الاعراف
والمواثيق
ومجتمع ظالم يقف مكتوف
الايدي لا يستطيع ان يحرك
ساكنا او يوقف
عدوانا لا باس فالشعب الفلسطيني ومقاومته
الابيه على
الدوام اقوى واكبر من كل محاولات التصفيه
البائسه يا جماهير
شعبنا ويا كل الاحرار
والثوار اننا امام استمرار الحرب
والعدوان وتغول العدو في دماء الابرياء
والمدنيين ومع دخول المعركه شهرها
الرابع نؤكد على ما
يلي
اولا ان هدف العدو المعلن بالقضاء على
المقاومه لم ولن يتحقق بامر الله ولو
استمرت الحرب الى ما لا
نهايه ومن يريد ان ينزع
سلاحنا سنز روحه ان شاء
الله
ثانيا بفضل الله
تعالى ما زال مقاتلونا في
الميدان يستبسل كل يوم بالدفاع
والمواجهه على جميع محاور تقدم العدو في
قطاعنا
الصامد
علما ان ما يحدث في
الميدان على ايدي
المجاهدين اكبر بكثير من ان توثقه كاميرات
المقاومه
وهنا نعلن عن بعض من باس عملياتنا
البطوليه والتي كان
اخرها اسقاط طائره استخبارات
صهيونيه في سماء مدينه خان يونس
والاستيلاء على ما فيها من معلومات
هامه استفادت منها وحداتنا العامله
ميدانيا بشكل
كبير وبفضل الله تبارك
وتعالى اطبق مجاهدو بعدها على اليات العدو
بقذائف الهاون
والصواريخ والاسلحه
المناسبه
فضلا عن الاجهاز على قوه صهيونيه
خاصه تحصنت في احد
المباني وحققنا بفضل الله اصابات مباشره
محققه وسنعرض لاحقا ما يؤكد ذلك بمشيئه
الله
تعالى
ثالثا نوجه التحيه الى ابطالنا ومجاهدينا
في كتائب صرايا القدس بالض
الغربيه ولا سما في مناطق التوغل في طول
كرم
وجنين وفي كافه مناطق الاشتباك بعموم
الضفه
المحتله اولئك الرجال الذين البوا
الاحتلال بعبوات الناسفه والتي كان اثرها
واضحا جليا وعلى مراى الجميع في جباته
والياته التي تحولت الى خرده
وخراب في حي الجابريات بجنين
طوالبه رابعا
واخيرا نحذر المستوطنين
الصهاينه ونقول
لهم بان دعوه نتنياهو لكم بقرب عودتكم الى
غلاف
غزه هي استمرارا منه لبيع الوهم
والسراب وقرارنا في
المقاومه بانه لا عوده ولا استقرار باذن
الله طالما استمرت الحرب وطالما استمر
القتل
والنزوح وسيكون للمقاومه فعلها وكلمتها ان
شاء
الله
ختاما لقد مضى ما مضى من المجازر بحق
المدنيين والابرياء
ولعل الانجاز الابرز لجيش
العدو هو براعه تدمير الحجر والبشر
باطمان المتفجرات
الامريكيه التي كشفت زيف العالم ومن يدعون
الايمان بحقوق
الانسان ومع كل ذلك لن يكون في نهايه
المطاف امام
نتنياهو الا التسليم بما يقضي به الميدان
والذهاب صاغرا مرغما الى هزيمته التاريخيه
المدويه بامر
جهادنا
مستمر وعملياتنا
متواصله والطائفه المنصوره لا تهزم باذن
الله والله اكبر والعزه للاسلام
والمسلمين والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته